if your creativity is sort of in a slump
and you don't feel challenged by it what
are some possibly even physical
activities that you can do I know Julia
Cameron always suggests going on writer
states or artist states she called them
just doing something that visually
stimulates you what are some of the
things you recommend to people that
maybe they're successful they have
something they're doing that's that's
paying them well but their cycle and
they want to challenge that creativity
you know it it's a very interesting
question and I think it connects to a
larger issue of writer's block right
lock of course is a big problem that
writers every writer faces at some time
or another I think it's a big
misconception that writer's block comes
from some kind of a psychological
element that we face that oh I'm just
not in a creative place right now you
know I've been working on this story for
too long whatever the reason that we
come up with I find almost everytime
writer's block comes from not
understanding the true structure of the
story you're telling and buddish when I
say true structure I mean not only is it
hitting those key story beats that I
referred to a little earlier but is it
hitting the story beats that are unique
and right for that story and almost
always it comes down to that main
character because the main character
drives the story and the key to having a
truly creative script a truly creative
story unique from anything that
anybody's ever seen before including the
writer
is that unique main character because
that's the person that you know this is
a unique individual and that's the
unique individual that will drive the
story so whenever I see a right
who is running into creativity problems
running into writer's block of some sort
I always say go back to your main
character find out what is unique about
that person that you haven't thought of
so far and find out what is unique about
that character that you are passionate
about why do you want to tell this
person's story once you focus in on that
character and the unfolding of that
character over the course of this story
then you will get back in touch with
your real creativity and I find almost
every time that that will break the
writer's block and break very quickly
you